we've got some breaking news from Great
Britain this morning the worldwide wait
is over we are coming on the air right
now because there is a Royal baby a baby
boy for Prince Harry and Duchess Megan
we're both absolutely thrilled and so
grateful to all the love and support for
everybody out there from everybody out
there it's been um it's been amazing
[Music]
Prince Harry and Megan Markel finally
welcomed their first born a baby boy at
5:26 a.m. Monday morning and the entire
world is celebrating right along with
them it's been an amazingly exciting day
here in Windsor good wishes immediately
began rolling in from across the pond I
don't want my social media to feel like
a newsfeed
oh she's not just my friend she's my
lawyer Megan's former suits co-star
Sarah Rafferty tweeted her
congratulatory message for the new
parents quote hearts are leaping for a
beautiful wondrous and healthy baby boy
sending much love and wishes for every
blessing across the pond today and every
day the husband I've always wanted and I
can't wait to begin our adventure and
m'aimes former on-screen hubby Patrick
Jay Adams wrote just heard that the
world just got heavier by 7 pounds and 3
ounces much love to him and his
incredible parents learned firsthand 7
months ago how transformational becoming
a parent is and couldn't be happier from
Megan and Harry as they begin this
adventure
hashtag playdate soon
when you told us to bring it at the
Invictus games careful what you wish for
former First Lady Michelle Obama
tweeted congratulations Megan and Harry
Barack and I are so thrilled for both of
you and can't wait to meet him
hashtag Royal baby and Barack Obama
retweeted the message here's hoping the
Obama's first time meeting baby boy
Sussex is just as adorable as their
introduction to Prince George newlywed
Priyanka Chopra shared making Harry's
baby announcement on her IG stories
writing congratulations
M&H and Ellen DeGeneres inserted her
famous humor tweeting the baby is
seventh in line for the throne which is
crazy because right now I'm seventh in
line for the key making kiosk
at my grocery store while Ryan Seacrest
referenced Game of Thrones writing the
Royal baby is seventh in line to the
British throne and the latest entry in
the race for the Iron Throne if you see
something that you don't like or
offended by on to on television or any
other place write letters and send them
to the right people and you can really
make a difference for not just yourself
with lots of other people Nickelodeon
honored the new mama by remembering her
famous in 1893 campaign and writing the
hashtag royal baby is here remember when
a young Meghan Markel wanted to change
the world on Nick news
even the Ravens master of the world
famous London tower tweeted it's a boy
hashtag Royal baby congratulations
[Music]
but perhaps the cutest tribute was that
from London's own Paddington Bear who
tweeted how exciting mrs. bird has said
we're going to have an extra special
afternoon tea to celebrate with
marmalade sandwiches ice cake and a few
cups of her lovely hot cocoa with cream
now as for the royal couple's family et
has learned that m'aimes mom Doria
Ragland was there to support Megan and
Harry during the birth we do know is
that the family on our bonding as a
family of three with Toria keeping a
watchful eye over them all at Frogmore
cottage here in Windsor and Megan's dad
Thomas Merkel offered his well wishes
via a very formal statement quote and
delighted to hear that mother and child
are doing well adding I am proud that my
new grandson is born into the British
royal family and I am sure that he will
grow up to serve the crown and the
people of Britain with grace dignity and
honour
[Music]